here's the thing Emma for you what is
the hold that the Spice Girls have over
you is this real yes it's real and I
just feel like I've been talking more
about the Spice Girls on this press tour
than I have about the movie you wet eyes
Australia I know I wept
did you really week I really did but now
which one was talking to you Mel B I was
she really told you was it a message no
it was a video message on an iPad and
that made you cry huh
what were you jet-lagged yeah also you
don't I mean I can you do understand
because we're in the UK I was I was a
fiend I was obsessed with the Spice
Girls and they taught me about girl
power
and I love them I think they're
fantastic and I'm also song there's so
many Jamie there's so many whoa bicep
your life every born every go myself
your life there's so many and they're so
fantastic and today on the radio Mel C
talked to me over Skype
oh so it's really very exciting okay
that who would you say is your favorite
Spice Girl Emma Bunton Baby Spice she's
your favorite she's my fan who's next to
that just a question all of the other
four
so ever Bunton well Emma Bunton was the
one that I had blonde hair and bangs and
my name obviously is now Emma my name
was Emily but it was taken when I became
an actor um and so now with Emma and uh
yeah I just I love so get me this so you
one
gave you a video message and one talked
to you on skype yes what are you telling
me you've never met are you gonna do
something have you never seen gonna be
something really have you never met a
Spice Girl
I'm wait hold on have you never met a
Spice Girl riding the flash okay now
hello
as you know
Emma he's very rare it is very rare for
more than one Spice Girl
to appear together for any reason at all
so they're not here
we but as I'm reading I'm loud show me
the money know what I mean I'm saying
brother show me the money there's almost
a spider-man link because it starts off
with lights out like a power outage
lights out like a power